Hey it's Kamala Harris.
She's a rising star in the democratic party.
Almost an Obama-like hype around her.
Possibly the next President of the United
States!
Last week Senator Kamala Harris finally made
it official.
I am running for President of the United States.
The California Democrat is trying to position
herself as a reformer
who works tirelessly to correct the abuses
of the criminal justice system.
But the senator has one big problem: her long record as a law and order prosecutor.
Harris' new memoir, The Truths We Hold,
makes no mention of her past as an old school
drug warrior,
a defender of dirty prosecutors and a political
opportunist
who has made life more dangerous for sex workers.
Harris doesn't apologize for her previous
stances, even those she now disavows.
Instead she's decided to try and convince
voters she's always been a progressive prosecutor.
How do you reconcile your contradictory past
with what you claim to support today?
I've been consistent my whole career.
Here are some of the stories the Senator is
hoping you'll forget in the run up to 2020.
Harris' political rise has been propelled
by a years long, high profile campaign against
alleged sex traffickers.
What she's actually done is throw women in
jail for having consensual sex
while trampling on the rule of law to advance
her own political ambitions.
Ignoring the pleas of sex workers and human
rights advocates for over a decade,
she's fought against campaigns to decriminalize
consensual adult prostitution in California.
As Attorney General she created a statewide
program
to get truckers to report suspected sex workers
to police.
These policies didn't stop traffickers, but
they did land plenty of sex workers behind bars.
One of the greatest offenders is backpage.com.
Harris fought to destroy backpage.com,
a classified site that sex workers used to
find and screen their clients.
Even though she publicly admitted that the
sites founders, Michael Lacy and James Larkin,
were protected from prosecution under federal
free speech laws.
But tonight, a groundbreaking arrest.
But a month before election day in her Senate
race, Harris went ahead and had them arrested anyway,
parading them before the cameras on pimping
charges
which were then promptly dismissed by a judge.
When Harris got to Congress she kept up her
crusade,
becoming a big proponent of the 2018 law known
as SESTA/FOSTA.
One cannot cowardly sit behind a computer
committing their crime, quite the contrary.
The result was that many sex workers had no
choice but to return to the streets
where soliciting clients is considerably more
dangerous.
It's cause you don't know who's gonna pick
you up.
Meanwhile Harris declined to intervene in
a real underage sex trafficking scandal
that involved dozens of police and other local
authorities in the bay area.
America has a deep and dark history
of people using the power of the prosecutor
as an instrument of injustice.
I knew this history well, of innocent men
framed,
of prosecutors hiding information that would
exonerate defendants.
Yes and as California's top cop, Harris contributed
to that history repeatedly.
By going to bat on behalf of dirty prosecutors.
Her office appealed the dismissal of a case
in which a prosecutor had fabricated a confession
to secure a conviction.
And fought an appeal in a case where a prosecutor
had lied to the jury during trial.
In 2015 Harris tried to stop the removal
of the Orange County District Attorney's Office
from a murder trial
after it repeatedly failed to turn over evidence
to the defense.
Her office even tried to keep a man in jail
who had been wrongfully incarcerated for 13 years
after a judge ruled that he had proven himself
innocent
just because the man hadn't delivered that
proof quite fast enough.
And as San Francisco DA Harris hid known misconduct
by a crime lab technician
who admitted to deliberately tainting evidence.
Prosecutors working under you know about the
concerns about that lab,
which is what the judge alleged.
-in my office did not know about it, at least
said they did not know about it.
The debacle has since led tot he dismissal
of hundreds of criminal cases.
Something else it's passed time we've done
is dismantle the failed war on drugs
starting with legalizing marijuana.
Your opponent Ron Gold has said that he is
for the legalization of marijuana recreationally
your thoughts on that?
Uhm, I, that he's entitled to his opinion.
Harris is a former drug warrior who is now
fashioning herself as pro legalization.
That's a positive shift, but not a reason
to rewrite the past
or ignore the patterns it reveals in her judgement.
For years after the cultural tide had turned
in favor of criminal justice reforms
Harris continued to support lock-em-up policies
that disproportionately hurt minorities.
As California Attorney General Harris opposed
marijuana legalization as late as 2014,
promoted civil asset forfeiture without a
conviction as a way to fight drug rings,
and sought to more aggressively police prescription
drug use.
In her new book, Harris reveals that her drug
warrior mentality hasn't changed
it's just that her emphasis has shifted.
We also need to reinstate the DA's authority
to go after the major pharmaceutical manufacturers
and distributors
and we need to invest resources and law enforcement
efforts
to cut off the supply of fentanyl from China.
Let's believe in a more perfect union, without
mass incarceration of African American men.
We put more people in prison than any country
on earth for no good reason.
Yes we do, and once these people were in prison
Harris saw to it that they have a hell of a time getting out.
I absolutely feel that there should be severe
and serious consequence for violent crime
which is why I prosecuted those cases and
will always seek the highest sentence.
As a prosecutor in law enforcement I have
a huge stick
so I decided I was going to start prosecuting parents
for truancy.
Before her recent about-face,
Harris chose not to endorse proposed sentencing
reforms on the California ballot in 2012 and 2014.
And she defended the constitutionality of
cash bail until 2016.
Harris' office also fought an order to reduce
California's prison population
after the Supreme Court determined that the
conditions amounted to cruel and usual punishment.
Although she later claimed to be 'shocked'
by what they had done,
Harris' attorneys argued that non violent
offenders should stay behind bars
because the state needed the cheap labor they
provide.
We are part of a longer story and we are responsible
for how our chapter gets written.
As she blazes her path to the White House
in 2020,
Kamala Harris is trying to rewrite her last
chapter, but her record remains.
Our children and our grandchildren will ask
at that inflection moment, where were you?
And what did you do in service of your family,
your neighborhood,
your community and your country?